[Applause]
Ms. Chancellor dear Angela Mr.
Chancellor Wolfgang Schuessel about
Norbert Lammert dear hans gert
pöttering Mr. Doctor Hassemer Mr.
Schwarz Mr. Dr Adenauer
ladies and gentlemen dear
guests 30 years ago the
news spread like wildfire that the border
was open with immediate effect
Thousands of people gathered through Berlin at the
border crossing of the GDR Surprised
border police officers finally gave in to the pressure of the
masses and opened the
barriers The rest is history
It is the images of joy and
hope that we have as a memory
when we
think of November 9, 1989
with us  after the fall of the wall,
a european freedom movement also found its
climax under the protective umbrella of the
western powers, western europe had
not only allowed the deep wounds of
two world wars to heal for decades, but
the free world had
reached out to western germany and accepted it back
into the circle of democrats  peoples
with all the turbulence that
everyday political life brings with it, germany will
always deeply thank the americans, the united kingdom and france in particular,
and in these thanks for decades of
freedom and security I would like to
explicitly include nato,
the most powerful defense alliance in the
world  a unique organization made up of
29 member states today the most recently
joined states know exactly what
nato is still worth today
our friends in the balkans and baltic states,
we germans in particular can
understand what life on the
border feels like in its 70-year
history, a lot has happened in the  nato
has changed but one thing has always remained the same
nato was and is always what its
member states make of
it it is up to 29 countries to get involved
and to change something
in words and deeds i think
nato has stood up to all bumps right down
to the last one
excellent for weeks as a protective shield of
freedom the long lines
count
the history of europe
cannot be achieved without nato that the
iron curtain fell has a lot
to do with the steadfastness of western democracies but also with the
indomitable longing for freedom of the
people in the east  as early as june 1989,
the hungarian foreign minister
gyula horn and his austrian
colleague cut a first hole in the
barbed wire that divided europe into
east and west and
the solidarity movement had
an overwhelming impact on poland in the first free elections they are
not alive today 30 years later  only
we germans are enemies again in the midst of
a peaceful europe today the
former countries of the warsaw pact are
an important part of our european
union
enemies have become friends the fact that
this happened was by no means as self-evident at the time
as it only
seems in retrospect that helmut kohl
succeeded in the  seizing the historic opportunity for
reunification
had a history adenauer
kiesinger brandt schmidt after the horror of war to
create new international trust in the new germany was the top priority for all
chancellors our luck is that they all
did much more than heal
and  to reconcile
they have invested far-sightedly and persistently in
a joint project
whose power only slowly became apparent
and is still continuing to unfold namely
in our europe a reunited
germany was unthinkable for many of our neighbors at the time without the
european framework
it is
the strength of the common idea that we had
at the time  was allowed to wear that and
we should never forget that when we look to the
future, the
auschwitz survivor simon wehen
said a few years ago in memory of the victims of the holocaust in the german federal parliament i quote you can
appreciate the moral victory that
the  the accession of the new
member states from the former
eastern bloc is taking place today in freedom and peacefully
and democratically quote
end after the war the
french woman became the first female president of the
european parliament ladies and gentlemen
tomorrow we will be celebrating the ninth of november there is
hardly a date that will lead us to
especially the  contradictions of german and
european history as
clear as this 9th of november on 9
november 1918 the spd politician
philipp scheidemann in berlin proclaimed the first
german republic the
triggers for this so-called
november revolution were, among other things,
the sailors in kiel they wanted against
a senseless order from the naval command
and refused to embark on
a last desperate battle in a lost war
the
new t november 1938 has gone down
in the darkest
part of our history as the day of the reichsprogromnacht
the ss henchmen and nazi
gangs marauding destroyed synagogues as well as
jewish shops and apartments
of jewish fellow citizens
were
free. wild until the catastrophe of the show
it was not far
on probably no day in german
history are good and bad hope
and shame courage and cowardice the
uplifting and the abyss of the people
as close together as on 9 november
the ninth of november is symbolic
For the self-doubt that creeps over us Germans
in the face of these contradictions,
but also for
the skepticism with which others still
view us today, but this
also allows us to appreciate the
blessings and gains
that a united Europe means for us Germans,
both internally and externally  as a
guarantor of peace, human rights, the rule of
law, as a guardian of tolerance,
justice, solidarity and
equal rights for women and
men, a joint effort of which
we can be extremely proud and grateful
[applause]
our parents and grandparents
rebuilt germany from the rubble of war
the rescue of germany and  the rescue of
europe is identical said konrad
adenauer as early as 1946
i therefore think it is wrong if it is often
said today that remembering the
darkest sides of our past
no longer helps to justify why
the european member states
have to work more closely together it
is also correct that the
reference to the  peace work europe
alone is not enough to
describe what advantages the
european union brings us the generation of
my children can
no longer imagine a life without this europe
europe for my children home but
germany as well as lower
saxony easily unite
them because they have also internalized
that the beauty of europe
is precisely its diversity
europe has
fortunately become a matter of course in your life
that does not mean that we do
not have to re-establish this basic trust in europe every
day and
god knows europe faces major
challenges
you know them from exit the growing strength of
populists  the trade dispute between
the usa and china is burdening our
companies and economic
development in europe the fragility of
our immediate neighborhood
my predecessor jean claude juncker
pointed out to you in his europe speech here that in a few
decades only five percent of all
people will be european
no  the only european
member state will then make up more than
one percent of the world's population
but i am firmly convinced that
strengths can grow from these supposed and sometimes actual weaknesses of europe the
power of the idea of ​​europe is unbroken
there is no challenge for europe
that does not come with the
a good example of this is indeed
trade policy
yes that is correct in a world in which
the relative weight of europe is declining
while many eu member states alone are
too weak to effectively negotiate with the usa about tariffs, for example,
or about a  free trade agreement with
japan but together we are 500
million and make up 40 percent of the
global gross domestic product together
we are the largest
trading power in the world together
we can negotiate a trade agreement that
not only benefits our economy
but with which we can also assert our values
is another example
digitization the web opens up
great new knowledge spaces economy
social participation creates innovation but
that also has its price
if you google your name
you will have information about what you have been doing in less than a second
sometimes right sometimes you feel
it is wrong that  net knows more about
you than your closest friends
even more so the big tech companies are
not so interested in what you
did yesterday as what you will do
tomorrow
eat buy
and above all why you do that
every click trains algorithms and
makes your behavior calculable this
data  are gold will they are
traded but not with
the user but between other
companies in a largely regulatory
free space europe has started to
trade the name is very dry
the effect is great basic data protection
regulation meanwhile professionals
also outside of europe refer to this
pioneering work as  gift to the world
why no other global force than
europe would have this gets in the us
the market traditionally comes first
and the government is
generally reticent in asia it is exactly the
opposite the government tends
to dominate and the group is seen as
much more than that  individual the result
is the same the
individual stands behind the market
and behind the state completely different
europe we have a long
tradition of balancing the influence of state and
market again and again and
above all
giving the highest priority to the individual
this is a cultural imprint for europe
a big advantage when shaping
digitization the world needs
more europe here and it is not too
late
we are still at a very
early stage of digitization of
course progress in the
right direction is not a
matter of course for europe it is
hard work and we have to  stay tuned
the european companies have
introduced the basic data protection regulation
as a result new ecosystems have emerged
that set standards for others
who work with them that means
this is indeed about
standardization and it is about
sovereignty
it is about protecting the sovereignty
of the individual and his  full
control over your own data
it's about competition it's about
standardization in this field
europe has acted out of its common strength
and that describes what is
special and beautiful about it
in this field europe had the power
to give back some of that sovereignty to the member states  that you and
your citizens have
long since lost to the data giants in the globalized world
that is the
key that we need namely the
common strength that we
as europeans can develop together in
practice is a good example of how
europe can emerge from the crisis with new ones  strength draws
yes i mean the exit quite clearly in advance
we all regret that our british
friends want to leave us but the
experience of the brh exit has opened the eyes of many who
doubt the european union
what they have in the
european union
the brh exit was not like  initially
wrongly suspected
to start a disintegration process for
the european union on the contrary, no matter how
different we all are at
the breaks it negotiations, 27
european countries stand together without malice
without cynicism with a common,
solid position we defend
our principles, for example the four
basic freedoms of the  market and our
values
and as paradoxical as it sounds, the shock of the
brh exit hit us harder because it
not only shows what it means
to leave the european union, but
also how much every country gains as
part of the european union the strength
of the common idea carries us  once
again
[applause]
ladies and gentlemen, when people in the
east overthrew their regimes in 1989,
they did so because they
wished for a better future for themselves and for their country,
just as we are looking at 1989,
the next generation will be us
in 30 years we will measure whether we have the courage to
shape tomorrow
[applause]
the task of the young people who
are demonstrating on the streets today is
quite unmistakable
it is our responsibility
to fight climate change and give them a
planet worth living in
we must therefore make courageous decisions
invest in innovation and research and make an economic and
industrial policy that
is geared towards the future and we can and
must make it so that europe
becomes the first climate-neutral continent by 2050
[applause]
i am of course also aware that europe
is only responsible for nine in quotation marks  up to ten percent of
global greenhouse gas emissions but
europe can take the lead e.g. in
low-co2 technologies it can show
that climate investments are profitable and
sustainable europe
can show how
structural change creates new skills and
new jobs
it can use the example of the
circular economy to prove that both
society and companies can start
and that is why i will present the
first european climate protection law
that translates this political goal into
binding law
we need massive investments
will propose an investment plan for a
sustainable europe and will
be able to convert parts of the european investment bank into a climate protection bank in this way  over the next ten
years we will mobilize a trillion euros in
investments and
promote climate protection in all areas of politics and economics and
bring it forward we only have this one
earth and we have been overexploiting it for long enough
the topic cannot be postponed
the topic cannot be postponed either  outsource to a
bailout fund we have to
act now and
[applause]
and if we do it well if we
do it well that's the beauty of it
not only is it good for our planet
because if we do it well
others will follow china is now leading by
example  also trades certificates for
co2 emissions and takes us as a
role model you are with us on the
commission to learn what mistakes you have
made and where we
have had good experiences if we
do it right then europe will be a pioneer
for climate-friendly
financing models  then europe is an
exporter of green innovations then
europe can be a role model for a
social transition to a resource-
saving life, work and
production
in short, europe can become a trendsetter
if we resolutely seize the power of the common idea
and
trust this power,
ladies  and gentlemen after the end of the
cold war, many believed that
the triumph of liberal democracy
could not be stopped you all know
the concept of the end of history
today we have to admit to ourselves that
our complacency is naive i am
thinking of russia the kremlin is using
violence to move established borders in europe  and tries to fill every vacuum
that the usa left behind i
think of china where hopes
for a convergence with the western
model were not fulfilled
30 years ago a few months before
the wall fell in berlin on 9 november tanks
rolled across the square
in beijing  heavenly peace
the federation of german industry speaks
of an open system of competition with a view to between
china is big
and it is taking action with impressive
determination nevertheless there is
no reason to be timid
as long as we europeans stand together and
confidently use our undisputed abilities
europe is more attractive today  as we
often know it ourselves or at least
talk about it we may be getting older in
europe it's getting older about russia and china
also has something to do with the
one-child policy but what we have or
we have something that is priceless
democracy openness to rights instead of freedom
many life plans
young people in china and
russia don't think that europe's open
societies combine
entrepreneurial spirit and a desire for freedom
they offer stability and a social
market economy
with us researchers not only find
funding for their projects but
also good schools for their children without having to
pay thousands in school fees
nursing staff can  not
only earn money in europe, but also
catch up on the Abitur at night school and young
people in europe do not need
wealthy parents to study abroad
an erasmus scholarship is enough in europe
you can take the
high-speed train
from brussels to paris in just over an hour
or with  the overnight bus
from fribourg to
prague for little money our healthcare systems are among the best in the
world i have already spoken about our pioneering role in
climate protection
i am deeply convinced
that this europe will remain
an attractive address in the digital age,
also in relation to the usa
china
we must continue to trust the power of the
common idea and
confidently go our own way in
europe
[applause]
american political scientists
coined the term soft power for this the idea behind it is that
political influence can also grow on cultural attractiveness
that is something very precious it is
of course only half the battle soft
power alone is no longer enough today
if we europeans want to hold our ground in the world
europe must also learn the language of power
as the designated
military commissioner put it that means on the
one hand building our own muscles which we have been using for a
long time  others could support us,
for example in security policy,
on the other hand, we could use our existing strength more
purposefully where european
interests are at stake i just
talked about china, yes, it is an important
trading partner for europe, but vice versa,
the european union is the largest
trading partner for china,
we can set the conditions  influence those with
whom we do business and we have been
doing so for a long time. we are happy about
every foreign company that takes part in
tenders in the european union,
be it for the construction of
motorways or power lines, but
in future we will pay more attention to ensuring
that these companies also comply with
our standards
for example, in terms of working conditions or
environmental protection conditions we are
open to investments
they are proof of how
competitive our technology
companies and world market leaders are
nevertheless we have to put limits on the unbridled
buying spree of often state-
subsidized foreign
companies we think it’s
good that the big
technology companies in the
european  union do business but
you can only do that because we have a good
infrastructure because the people
here have a good education good jobs good
social security
system so we also expect
these technology companies to
pay taxes at a reasonable rate because they use all of this
[applause  ]
we have to
become more strategic with regard to europe's external interests
this also applies to
enlargement policy issues that the western balkans
have a european perspective is in
our own best interest
[applause]
we share the same history
we share the same continent have
the same culture and the same
challenges  we have asked a great
deal of north macedonia and
albania
they have fulfilled all of this now
we must also stand by our word and
facilitate accession talks
[applause]
and we must also consider that if we
europeans do not give the western balkans a
perspective on our side then
others will in  this gap is being filled
by china or russia or
turkey or saudi arabia and we
shouldn't forget the european
perspective that the heads of state and
government promised back in 2003 at the
western balkan summit in thessaloniki
was shaken by bloody conflicts just 20 years ago and how much time it
takes
when our union opens its heart that
has been impressively demonstrated by the history of the european
union since 1989
when we talk about the western balkans
we also remember the exceptional
situation in autumn 2015 as a daily occurrence
thousands of migrants arrived at the german-
austrian border
when we talk about migrants today
we are only talking about a small
fraction of this number the basic question has
still not been fully answered
how can we deal with migration in
our immediate neighborhood
in the future i have had many
many conversations since the summer  led by european heads of state
and government
alm it is clear that europe cannot
continue like this even those who
block it are clear that the phenomenon
of migration will not simply go away
migration will remain and the good
news is they want to get back to the
table and they prefer to
talk about sustainable solutions  and it is also
clear to you that every member state
must contribute to this solution in solidarity i believe that there is a window for
a fresh start on the issue of migration
some guard rails will
apply in any case
europe will remain an open continent
that is not in exchange with the world
barbed wire is part of the
european way of life, but
cross-border research, travel,
trade,
as well as the right of asylum and the protection
of the weakest,
but we must not
promise more than we can keep,
i don’t have a simple solution in my quiver either,
but what i can tell you is
that  my commission
will do everything in its power from day one to work on this topic, which
is so important for the inner stability of our community,
and to
present a proposal in the first half of 2020.
i am here, too, confident that in the end
the european idea will prevail, together
we will overcome the challenges
which each and every one of us
would be overwhelmed
ladies and gentlemen when was
born in brussels more than 60 years ago
the european union had a different name back then
six member states are now a
lifetime later there are 28
no one was forced
to join this european union
everyone joined  voluntarily
decided to do so and have
worked incredibly hard to achieve this goal
30 years after the fall of the wall,
europe has developed into an opportunity that has come true for many people
30 years
after the peaceful revolution,
we can be proud
of the courage of the east and the  has brought western
europe back together for 30
years young people have known
nothing but a europe of freedom for
them it is part of their identity
to study across borders to work,
live and love
this is the real wealth of europe
we can enjoy this wealth because
others  who previously stood up for peace and freedom
30 years ago people had the
courage to overcome lack of freedom and to
dare the future
that's exactly what we need now courage for
Europe courage for a Europe of freedom
courage for a Europe that stands by its values
courage for a Europe that
courageously takes his future into his hands
when i moved to stanford university in california with my husband as a young woman
but i was impressed by the coat of arms
of this californian university it
bears the words of the german
poet and philosopher johann gottlieb
spruce
it says the  air of freedom is blowing
today on this memorable day for us
germans we can say with some pride
somewhere in the world this sentence applies
more than in the european union long
live europe
[applause]